juste jean paul steijns est-ce qu'on
peut attraper le kobe de l'acolyte de
foi ou pas deux fois
oui il a il ya quelques publications qui
montre effectivement que certaines
personnes attrapent l'acolyte de ça peut
vite être vide ces dix ses terres
maladie donc le virus et le strass et ça
c'est un strict devoir arles en
pourparlers dans le jargon donc donc ça
arrive il ça arrive c'est rare d'accord
c'est vraiment rare d'accord mais ça
pose quand même une question bien ça
pose une question de savoir combien de
temps dure l'immunité 7h et combien de
temps dits durs l'immunité ça
conditionne le vaccin ah oui et aussi le
vaccin dans des populations différentes
et fragile qui répondent par nature
moins bien aux vaccins donc là il ya
toute une série d'interrogations pour
lesquels pour l'instant on n'a pas
encore une réponse faire auteur la
saison il n'a pas continué comment ils
te la suède qui n'a pas confiner la
chine portionné lmnp le nombre de morts
mais sait s'arrêter moins importants que
jean il est plus importante chez nous
s'est il est cadre ou quoi la même heure
la mortalité chez nous d'accord car des
fois on nous dit de nous dit qu'ils ont
misé sur l'immunité collective c'est à
dire la même année était de plus en plus
marcher ils sont plantés ça n'a pas
marché ça n'a pas marché alors vraiment
il faut arrêter de dire que les français
sont pas responsables ils ont toujours
fait ce qu'on leur a dit de faire
sauf que quelques exceptions quand on a
demandé aux gens de se confiner ils se
sont confinés dans la situation très
difficile des jeunes dans les
appartements des familles qui ont dû
assumer totalement l'éducation de leurs
enfants
quand on leur a dit ce des consignes et
on leur a pas donné de règles on leur a
pas donné dragon n'a autorisé des
manifestations et des gens entassés
on a autorisé l'ouverture des
restaurants d'une certaine façon on a
autorisé les choses on n'a rien
contrôler laurent ça y est vous êtes
venu d'être devenu très démago vous dis
la vérité excusez moi non mais c'est
vrai je vous vous êtes beaucoup à l'ol
je sais qui c'est arrivé alors il à
chaque à chaque fois là franchement
c'est un discours de démagogie
absolument pas mais regardez les jeunes
les jeunes qui sont sortis du
confinement
quand il se sent renta saison les bons
représentez-vous leur tournée en folie
ramed allait nous quitter mais l'engin
non mais je trouve que la voir dit elle
avoir des bons commentaires sur twitter
wow la pose et la pensée profonde
vous avez dit et je pense que si on
avait des gens à 110 étaient tellement
donné naissance à des gestes de sortir
de votre démagogie comme la dignité
on la trouve patrick ou non mais il ya
un concept de responsabilité partagée il
ya aussi un concept d' irresponsabilité
partagée ce qui laisse pas y avait des
manières par contre que ce nom que c'est
certains consommateurs ont tous fait
preuve d'irresponsabilité
c'est que c'est là où il faut tous les
français de son merveilleux ils sont non
c'est pas vrai il ya une partie
donc faisons le distinguo entre ce
qu'ils ont respecté et ceux qui vont le
respecter
est ce que le gouvernement fait ce
distinguo a dû tout ça c'est pas de la
démagogie ou parce que vous avez tous
les deux raison il ya aucune prévention
via mail à plusieurs reprises que ça ne
marchera pas un vêtement popu nié à
plusieurs reprises
c'est pour prévenir au kayak il faut
quand même reconnaître que le
gouvernement a dit plusieurs fois sur
différents tons attention et onillon di
una interdit mais il y avait des
décembre et non je dis oui rires
j'étais là